Oh, sorry about that.
Oh, can you pass the ball back?
Hey, uh...
You okay there, buddy?
Oh, man.
Oh, you...
Sorry, I did not see you, Dragoon.
Oh, hey.
Hey.
You're not gonna sue, right?
It was just an accident.
Hey, come on.
It's just, like, a flesh wound, right?
You didn't have a concussion or anything.
Come on, it was just a beach ball.
Come on, get up, Dragoon.
Come on.
Dragoon?
Oh, come on.
Are you okay there?
Dragoon?
Hello?
Hello, Dragoon?
Oh, there you go.
Wow.
Okay, you...
You scared me there.
Oh, man.
I thought you were never gonna wake up.
Hey.
Wait, what's this?
Feels like you dropped some stuff.
What are these?
Dropped a bunch of paper here.
Oh.
Wow.
Did you draw that, Dragoon?
Oh.
There's fan art.
Oh, you're those Dragoons.
They're probably my fan club, right?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, the whole beach episode or whatever.
Oh, I didn't...
I thought you'd be, like, you know, at home.
Why are you out here?
I'm at the beach touching sand.
Oh, wow.
Oh, man.
I guess that's what you think I'm gonna wear, right?
Well, at least you got the Crocs right.
Oh, you also have...
Oh, this one from...
Nav.
Oh, man.
All of you guys got the Crocs right, though.
I guess, I mean, it's sort of obvious that, of course, I'm gonna wear Crocs.
Like, what else would I wear when you're walking on the beach?
Especially when you're touching the water.
The fucking fish toilet.
I like how a lot of you guys are wondering, like, what exactly type of swimwear am I gonna wear?
Um...
Uh, am I gonna wear during...
This beach episode.
I like how this one...
I like...
Oh, man, Dragon.
I like how this one...
You guys basically gave me a military gear.
Um...
A little military beret.
Oh, you thought...
Oh, my God.
Wait, I just noticed you guys thought that it was a beret.
The beach beret.
I'm always locked in wherever I go.
A little...
A little knife for, like, in case there's a criminal at the beach.
Hey, still got the Crocs.
You guys got that correct.
All right, what else did you guys submitted?
Oh, I...
Oh, this one's cute.
Ooh.
The transparent shirt.
And then also the...
The belly button.
Oh.
How much skin is she gonna show today?
Crocs, thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you.
See, I knew you guys weren't gonna sue me.
I...
I knew you guys weren't gonna sue me.
I mean, it was just a beach...
It was just a beach ball.
Come on.
That didn't hurt, guys.
Um...
And also there's the Crocs.
Yet again.
I don't think...
I think everybody sort of knew that...
I was gonna be wearing Crocs to the beach.
I mean, it's, like, the most efficient, anyway.
Uh...
When you're out there, um...
When you're out there, like, with the sand and the ocean.
Because the worst part is getting sand in your shoes.
But then if you're wearing Crocs...
The sand can just flow out of the holes, you know?
Uh...
Here's another one.
I like this one because you included Chonky Goon.
Oh!
A lot of you guys realize...
Um...
For those who don't know...
All my...
Debut teasers...
My outfit teasers...
Always includes elements...
That come from my outfit.
So...
Um...
Uh...
Some of you guys predicted it...
Correctly...
When it came to, uh...
The water balloons...
And what their purpose was.
So...
Some of you guys realized that they were water balloons...
And that I may or may not have some of them on me right now.
So...
But where will it...
Where are they gonna be?
Well, you guys are gonna have to look up and find out.
Whenever you're ready to get up.
Okay, Dragon, I know you're still... I know you're still on the ground right now.
But whenever you're ready to get up from the ground because you don't have a concussion, right?
You don't have a concussion and you're not going to seek any legal action on me.
Right, guys?
So, whenever you're able to look up and, you know, get up, then you'll know where the water balloons are.
Um, oh, here's another one.
Um, I like how Dad is, like, in my little baggie here.
Uh, because you guys are, like, wondering, oh, obviously, whenever I have a new outfit, Dad will also get something, too.
And I like that you guys put him in a little pouch there.
Like, you know, those types of dogs that, like, can't fucking walk.
Uh, well, not as in, like, they can, but they don't want to.
Sorry, those dogs...
Weird thing for me to say after what he's been through.
Uh-huh, but I meant with those who...
For the dogs that don't want to walk because they're, like, ew, sand.
Uh, I don't want to be, like, carried everywhere.
Yeah, the pocket dogs.
Uh, uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh.
Um, I really like that feature and I like that, yeah.
I like that this one is a little different from the rest because, uh, you made me tan here.
That was pretty neat.
Awesome.
Whoa, sorry.
Uh, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And then more Crocs.
I think everybody got the Crocs correctly.
Everyone knows what shoes they are.
Except...
Oh, yeah, see, he's still Crocs.
Haha.
And then...
This is one by...
Oh, this one's by Zavik.
Um, I love all the designs you have on my water gun.
Um, obviously, it's not a real gun.
We're at the beach.
I don't bring a gun to the beach.
Uh, it is made of water.
I love all the little designs you guys come up with for the little water gun, too, and everything.
And then, oh, I love looking at you guys.
You know, I love looking at these...
Oh my gosh, I love looking at these designs because they actually help me a lot coming up with, like, future outfits for my skin suit.
So, it really does help a lot when you guys do these predictions because I get to, like, you know, get inspiration for future color schemes and future ideas.
That one used for newer outfits.
Oh, wait, are these sandals?
Oh!
You won the jack!
You won the lottery, Maria!
Not Crocs!
Oh my gosh, wait, what are these in the front?
Are those, like, syringes?
Oh, it's like I'm collecting stuff at the sand.
Oh, I love the dad fit, though.
Like, the dad at the beach.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Actual dad at the beach outfit.
May or may not be correct in your prediction.
Ha ha ha!
May or may not be.
You're gonna have to get up to see what it really is.
And then this one.
Oh, this one's cute!
The little...
Aw!
The little sunglasses for dad!
And then, like, my little clips and my band...
Oh, I've always wanted, like...
Maybe in the...
Okay, I'll say that I do not have a bandaid on my face.
Uh, but it is something that I really wanna do in the...
For the future.
In the future outfit.
To have the, like, bandaid on the nose thing.
Cause I feel like that's such a classic tomboy trope.
And I always wanted to have that for an outfit.
But it didn't work for this one.
It didn't work for this one.
Maybe in the future.
I'm like, yoink!
My idea now.
Ha ha ha!
Um, what else do I have here?
Oh, I have this one from...
Uh, Laszlo...
Laszlo Finch.
Oh, more Crocs.
Nice.
Ha ha ha!
Oh!
This time, you...
Instead of, like, a...
Some people think it's a bag.
Some people think it's a beach ball.
Well, you're gonna have to find out...
You're gonna have to, you know...
Get up from the sand to see what it really is.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
And then there's, like, the sling bag.
And everything.
And then there's the school book here.
Okay, what else do you have in this collection of paper you have here?
Oh, I...
I...
I really love the color scheme for this one.
I think...
This one's from Monfa.
But I love the color scheme for this Hawaiian shirt.
Uh, when I first saw this.
Ha ha ha ha!
The skin tight swimsuit!
Damn!
Ha ha ha!
Sorry, I just noticed...
I was too focused on the colors.
To fit...
See the in...
I was wearing on the inside!
Ha ha ha ha!
The skin tight swimsuit!
Ha ha ha!
Thaccoon's enjoying the view.
That's for sure.
Ha ha ha ha!
At least...
At least people...
At least people will know...
That I'm not a washing board!
Ha ha ha!
I told you it was a sports bra, guys!
I...
Ha ha ha!
Um...
Oh, I like...
Oh, wait!
I just noticed this, too!
There's like a...
There's like a bird at the end of the gun, too!
Oh!
And then there's more...
More Crocs!
Yes!
I think that was the most obvious part of the whole silhouette!
Alright, what else?
What else?
Oh, this one's cute!
Oh!
I love the little...
The little...
Um...
See-through tank top!
I think that's what they're called, right?
Um...
From Renkai.
The...
The little...
I like this color scheme a lot.
Oh, this...
Yoink...
I'm gonna...
Yoink my color...
Ha ha ha!
The fishnets...
Is it called fishnets?
I don't remember...
I don't know what they're...
This is called.
Um...
I really love the color scheme that you got here.
And now it's my color scheme.
Ha ha ha!
Yeah!
The mesh and then the...
The inflatable see-through dragon...
And I don't know...
The color...
Color scheme...
And the combination for this is really, really cute.
And then like the...
The swim trunks with the little like palm leaves and everything.
Um...
And then my crocs with the...
The gibbets.
I recently found out what these are called.
They're called little gibbets.
But...
That's so cute.
Oh...
Aw, man.
That's a good idea.
Maybe like...
A future product...
Since I am wearing crocs right now...
That maybe we can have like...
You know...
Crotchet bits in the future.
Uh...
Ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
Yoink!
Ha ha ha!
And then the little inflatable dragon is so cute though!
Look at him!
Look at that little guy!
Alright, what else do I have in here?
What else?
Uh...
Did I look at this?
Oh, I already did.
Uh...
What about this one?
Oh!
This one's from...
Saria.
Aw, look!
Aw, like...
I like...
You know how like...
A lot of these like...
Since we're doing a beach...
A beach episode...
Like all the outfits are like...
Very tropical theme and everything.
So I do...
Oh my god!
Wait, I actually like these shoes.
Look at these.
The dragoon crocs.
The little faces in the front too.
Aw!
And then there's a tomato there!
Aw, that's so cute!
A little tomato for the end...
For like the...
The...
The green thing.
That's cute.
Yeah, see I told you.
It's a sports bra.
Ha ha ha ha!
It's...
I didn't stuff the chest!
It's all natural, chat.
Dragoons.
It's all natural, guys.
And then...
Um...
I definitely love this part the most too.
Ha ha ha ha!
I love this part too.
Wait, is this a...
Aw!
And then there's like a...
A waterproof dragoon watch.
A waterproof apple.
Wait.
Dragoon watch.
Yeah.
Um...
And then a little dragoon beach bar.
And my little bag and everything.
That's so cute.
Oh my gosh.
You guys have some really nice outfit predictions.
They're all really fucking adorable, chat.
Uh...
Ha ha ha ha!
Alright, what's about...
This one?
This one is from...
Ooh!
There's a lot of them.
This one from Cassia.
There's a lot of choices here.
Ooh!
Oh!
One of them is like a full scuba diving outfit.
For my scuba gear.
Or the like...
Wetsuit.
And then there's one with the chonky goon beach bar.
And then there's dad in a bag.
Uh...
There's nothing exaggerated!
Okay?
None of...
All these concepts are very real.
Uh...
Ha ha ha!
They're all a part of me.
Uh...
Surely in one of the Doki verses you will have these...
This outfit.
Um...
And then I like that the creativity since I was wearing a scuba gear.
In the silhouette.
He did show like...
You know...
A little diving suit too.
As well.
And then there's like the...
The little...
Uh...
Little...
What are we called?
The...
Privileged bag dogs.
Ha ha ha!
Oh!
And there's a little egg in there in my pocket!
I hope I don't accidentally scramble him.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
All right.
We'll look at one more guys.
One more outfit prediction.
Uh...
Oh...
Oh my god.
You guys are so many too.
Oh!
I'll do this one.
This one is by...
Uh...
Yami.
I like how you...
Oh!
You included like a little surfboard too!
Uh...
I cannot surf though.
I hate to break it to you guys, dragons.
I...
I don't know how to...
I don't actually know how to surf.
I feel...
I think you have to have like really good balance for it too.
Um...
And like...
Uh...
I remember like...
Yeah, you have to have really, really good balance for that shit.
And I don't have that.
I've done like those like balancing tests.
Um...
Where you have to like walk across like...
Walk across like a really thin like wooden board.
Um...
And I did not do so well.
Like if I...
It was like...
Oh, pretend you're crossing across like a cliff or something.
And you're doing those, like, you know, those, like, um, adrenaline junkies where they walk across, like, a tightrope and stuff.
So there was, like, this little test where it's, like, it goes from, like, a little wooden board and then a tightrope and then, like, um...
And then, like, it gets skinnier and skinnier.
And I did not... I... I... If I... If it was real life, I would have died after two seconds.
I... I... I took, like, two steps and I was off the cliff.
I was...
It... It did not go so well.
It...
Um... Um... But yeah, I really love the cute idea of having a surfboard next to me and then the little...
The little tomato water balloons and everything and then I'm choking the dragoon beach ball.
Anyway...
Dragoon, can you... Can you get up now?
Are you... Are you okay?
Remember, you're not gonna sue me, right?
It was... It was like, you know, just a little bump on the head.
Um... You already had that...
Um... You already had a headache before you came here, remember?
Come on!
You already had a headache because you were drinking earlier, weren't you?
Yeah, your... Your buddies were telling me.
Uh... Your buddies were telling me that you were drinking earlier at the bar.
So, like, come on.
Like, you had that headache already, guys.
Come on.
So, like, why don't you get up?
Yeah?
Why don't you get up?
Look, we can... Look...
If you want, I will write my fake... I mean, my real number to you.
So, like, you know, if you do have to go to a hospital, you can call me.
And then, like, my insurance will cover it.
Um... And I definitely have insurance.
Don't worry, Dragoon.
So, like, why don't you... Why don't you, like, get up?
Come on.
Yeah, that's right.
You're doing it.
All right.
Get up, Dragoon.
Come on.
All right.
You're almost there.
Come on.
That's... You're still at my legs.
You're still at my feet.
Are you staring at my ankle bracelet?
That's... That's a little weird.
That's... We're not in the 1950s anymore.
We can show our ankles now.
Come on.
Can't be that... Come on.
Oh my gosh, you're... It's very slow.
Yes, that skin.
Yes, I have... Of course, it's the beach.
I'm not gonna wear long pants at the beach, Dragoon.
Um... You're scaring me.
Um... I don't... I don't know...
Um... Okay, I'll let you in on a little secret.
I may or may not have insurance.
So, um... I really need you to be able to get up, Dragoon.
Um...
All right.
All right, all right, all right.
Come on.
You're almost there.
Oh!
Yep!
Those are my knees now!
Oh!
You wanna see my gun?
Yes!
Oh, yes!
That's a very real gun!
So, if you don't get up...
On the count of five, Dragoon!
Then...
I hate to say it, but...
I don't like witnesses.
I'm joking.
It's just water.
Don't worry, Dragoon.
It's...
It's just water.
See?
It's my little water gun here.
Oh!
Yeah!
Doki Bird.
From my Doki...
What does it say?
Oh, hey!
You can see my nails now!
Whoa!
Yeah!
You can see my nails, guys!
Black nails!
My black nail polish!
I went to the...
Oh, I went to get a manicure before I came here.
But yeah!
Oh, you see my shirt?
Yeah!
I made it myself!
From the Doki Bird brand!
Uh...
Like that!
Oh, you wanna see more?
Alright!
If you get up...
If you get up and you promise not to sue me...
Maybe you can see more of these clothes!
And maybe I'll give you a free sample, too!
It comes in all shapes and sizes!
Alright!
Let me...
Come on!
You got this!
Oh!
Yep!
That's my other hand!
Right here!
Hahaha!
Yeah!
Of course I named my brand...
Brand over me!
That's how branding works!
They'll be like...
Whoa!
Where'd you get it?
Oh!
It's Doki Bird from...
Doki Bird by Doki Bird?
What do you think Calvin Klein is?
You think Calvin Klein...
Is like...
A made up thing?
No!
It's his fucking name!
Calvin Klein by Calvin Klein!
That's what Louis Vuitton is!
Louis Vuitton by Louis Vuitton!
Of course it's Doki Bird by Doki Bird!
Doki Bird!
Hehehehehehe!
Hehehehe!
But yeah...
Oooh!
Oh!
You can see like the little dongles from my pants too!
Yeah!
Marked by Marc Jacobs!
Exactly!
I mean my clothes!
If my clothing brand like hits it big...
They'll be like...
Oh my god!
Who's Doki Bird?
Oh my god...
Where did you get that?
Yeah, I got it from Doki Bird.
Yeah, it's Doki Bird by Doki Bird.
Oh, you like the physics?
Yeah?
Don't worry, there's more physics later on.
Don't worry, Dragoon.
You promise you won't sue.
There's more physics where that come from.
I just need you to look up.
Whoa.
Come on.
Going very slow.
Whoa.
Oh, you see that?
Oh, you can sort of see the physics already, guys.
So...
So, remember a long time ago...
Back during the visage streams.
And...
Back during...
Back during the visage streams.
And...
And I was showing...
This...
To Mint.
And she was like...
What the fuck are those?
And I was like...
Oh, don't worry.
They have physics too.
You gotta always be prepared for a fight, Dragoons.
That's all I'll say.
Those are my...
You guys like my physics?
My jiggle physics?
Whoa.
There's so much water in here.
It's extra squishy.
Yeah.
Boing.
Whoa.
Is this the physics you guys wanted?
There's more than two.
I think there's four.
Whoa.
You know what they say.
Four balloons better than two.
I mean...
Come on.
You have two hands.
What are you gonna do it for?
Four.
It's...
I mean, you could fill it up with tomato juice too, if you wanted to.
Like, if you're...
If you really wanna win the war.
But...
You sure?
Yeah, they're balloons.
Look at that.
Whoa.
I mean, you don't know what's actually in there until I throw it at you.
So, like, it could be cat pee.
You guys...
You guys heard about that?
Like...
Um...
I think, like, some guy got arrested for throwing, like, cat pee at people.
I remember...
I remember, like, reading an article about it.
But, like, some guy was, like, throwing, like, water balloons filled with, like, cat pee at, like, random strangers at the beach.
So, like, that's gonna be...
But that's a story.
Oh, wait!
Oh, you see that?
Sorry, it's the summer, so...
Uh...
So, like, since, you know...
I'm Doki Bird.
You know, like, during...
During the winter, I was, like, molting.
So, like...
Uh...
So, you know how, like, some...
Some birds have, like, less feathers.
Uh...
During...
Wait...
Wait, actually, wait.
Do I know bird biology?
Give me a sec.
I might need to fact check this.
Okay, I'm a special bird.
Um...
But during the winter, I was molting.
So, like, when I was molting, um...
I didn't have my...
I didn't have my tail feathers.
But I'm Doki Bird.
So, like, obviously, you know, as a...
As an actual bird.
Uh...
I'm trying to remember my birdology.
Um...
But, like, I didn't have my tail feathers.
But, like, during the...
It's, like, during the summer, it just comes out.
It just grows out, you know?
Um...
Yes, I have a little bump in the...
In my back.
Um...
It's very tight.
It doesn't...
It's, like...
Okay, so, like...
You know how, like, when it gets warmer, the bulge...
Okay, how do I explain this properly?
When...
When it gets warmer, the...
The bulge grows.
And then feathers come out.
But when it's colder, like, my feathers come off.
Like, I just shed it all out.
Because I don't need it anymore.
Um...
Because, like, you know, when it's winter, I don't go outside.
And I hibernate a little bit.
Like, I half hibernate and I stay inside.
So I don't need to use my tail feathers.
Um...
To warm myself up.
And...
Please stop!
So, like...
During the summer...
Um...
My birdology...
Biol...
Physiology...
Realized...
Oh, it's summertime.
What time is it?
It's summertime.
It's our vacation.
I actually forgot I had to tell just now.
Um...
Uh...
So...
Does it sound like I'm making up as I go?
That's insulting.
I had to live with this for my whole life.
How dare you imply that I made it up as I made it up just now.
Anyway...
So, like...
During the summer...
Um...
The bulge starts growing back...
Uh...
On my back.
And because they're like, Oh my god, it's getting warmer.
We need...
We...
We need to...
Fly to the south.
So...
I mean, not fly...
Not fly to the south.
Sorry.
That's the winner.
I mean...
Oh, it's getting warmer.
You can have your tail now.
Anyway...
Um...
That's why I have a tail during the summer.
No idea...
Um...
Okay...
Yeah, so I can do my little tail...
My little bird dance too, you know?
I can like poof up and be like,
What is she happy about?
I forgot I had... No, I can't believe you are thinking... I can't believe you guys think I forgot I have a tail.
So now I'm trying to figure out how to include this tail lore into the Doki-verse.
But for this particular skin suit, the easiest way to remember is winter no tail, summer tail.
My tail lore.
Alright, anyway, let me go up now.
Woah, look at that.
Yeah, oh my god, look at this bounce.
Woah.
Alright, sorry, I love playing around with that physic.
Anyway, it is getting a little hot though, so I might have to...
Woah.
It is getting just a little hot, so I might have to... Let me just take this off a little.
Oh man, it's getting really, really hot, guys.
So I'll take off my shirt a little bit.
Can you hold that, Dragon?
Yeah, you can hold that for me for a little bit, right, guys?
Alright.
Woah.
You're almost there.
Come on, you're almost back up.
I believe in you.
You're almost back up.
Woah.
Woah, come on.
Just gotta get up a little bit more.
Yeah?
Come on.
You said you won't sue.
Come on, just look up.
When you look up, I can leave.
Legally, I have to make sure you're able to stand on your own before I can leave.
Woah.
I told you it's not flat.
Look, do you see that little bump right here?
Not little, sorry.
Do you see that above average bump right there?
I told you.
I told you I'm...
I told you there was something.
I...
Wait.
It's right there!
I told you it.
Don't you see?
It's right there.
Alright, okay.
Alright.
What?
The above average bump right there.
Anyway.
Oh, by the way.
Watch this.
When... You know how, like...
Um... you know how... you know, like when you warm up a cup and it...
There's those, like, those thermal cups.
So my shirt is actually a thermal shirt.
So, like, if it gets, like, uh, if it gets, like, too hot, like, right now.
God, it's so hot right now.
Oh, my God, because I'm here.
Anyway, so, like, you know how, okay, and then, like, it's so fucking hot, right?
And then, so...
Whoa!
You know, when it's so hot, my shirt is actually a thermal shirt.
So, it can actually, like, uh, turn, turn black when it gets way too hot.
Which is not the best, because it absorbs more sun.
But it's pretty cool, though.
It's, yeah, we're dark.
It's pretty cool.
But the only downside is that it does, like, absorb more of the sun.
So, it's even hotter.
So, like, it's a little difficult to turn it back.
But that's okay.
When I'm in the water, it turns back into...
It turns back to white.
See, like, if I just do this...
Look, like, a little bit of water touched me.
And now it's...
Now it's white again.
Ha ha ha!
The Lord is falling apart.
It's a...
It's a thermal shirt.
Look, I know it's, like, really dumb that it turns black when it's hotter.
Because now it's gonna be even hotter.
But, like, I didn't think about that when I...
When I invented this shirt.
Okay, guys?
Like, that's...
Ha ha ha!
I didn't...
I didn't think about that.
But now it's done.
It's done.
It's the...
It's the doki way.
Okay, all right.
Okay, now you ready?
Oh, hey.
You're all...
You're halfway there.
Actually, no, you're 80% there.
No, 90% there.
I don't know my math.
I...
Ha ha ha!
Just reverse the...
No!
I am committed to this science!
Okay?
I'm committed to it.
All right.
In three...
Two...
One!
You did it!
Ha ha ha!
Oh, wait.
I just realized I forgot something.
Where is it?
Yeah!
Ha ha ha!
Hello, dragoon!
So you can't...
Legally...
You can't sue me anymore because you're standing on your two legs right now.
And you seem fine.
So, like, I'm pretty sure you're okay now.
Ha ha ha!
Yeah!
You like my new look, dragoon?
Oh, you want to see more of the hair?
Of course.
Of course, as long as you don't sue.
Ha ha ha!
Oh, you like the...
Whoa!
This has physics, too.
Ha ha ha!
Yeah, it's like airplane mode.
And look, I have my...
Um...
My clip-ons because I don't have actual ear piercings because, um, I'm afraid of the pain.
Uh...
I'm really afraid of the pain getting my ears actually pierced.
So this is just clip-ons.
Like a clip-on tie, but for your ears.
And I got it at Claire's.
You guys like it?
For only $4.99 for the whole set.
Ha ha ha!
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
Oh, man.
It's getting so hot, guys.
Ha ha ha!
Let me put my...
Let me put...
Oh!
Oh, you notice something different?
So...
So my Hawaiian shirt...
Is actually...
Uh...
My Hawaiian shirt...
Is actually also a mood Hawaiian shirt.
I don't know what the colors mean yet.
So I can do...
So like, you know, this is on default.
And then...
This is...
This is on default.
And then it can like...
I don't know what I'm feeling when it turns light blue.
Um...
And then like...
And then sometimes it can also turn...
It can also turn white.
So like, I...
I have yet to figure out what mood go...
Goes for what.
But... It's like... It's like a chameleon scene.
My RGB Hawaiian shirt.
Yeah, that's right.
But, I don't know.
I don't know which one I like the most.
I don't know what is considered default.
Not gonna lie.
Because I do like this color palette.
And also this one, too.
So, with the white shirt.
So, I don't know which one I like the most for the Hawaiian shirt color scheme-wise.
But, they're both cute.
I find them both really, really cute.
I don't know if I like the teal more or the light blue more.
And you can get it from Doki Bird by Doki Bird.
Or I could... Or I could take it off.
Oh, yes!
I almost forgot.
JK, I didn't forget.
He's so cool.
Look at him.
He's so...
He's also on vacation.
He's also getting his own beach episode, as well.
Look at him.
That's right.
Right, Dad?
Yeah!
He also has his own Hawaiian shirt, too.
You see it?
You see his Hawaiian shirt, guys?
Oh!
I don't know why we got up.
Oh my god, he did a little jump.
But he has his own little Hawaiian shirt, as well.
Look at him.
He's so fly.
Alright, Dad.
Get out.
Get out of here.
But that's not all.
Because...
I can also do this.
Yeah!
Yo Kitty also is getting her very own beach episode.
But that's not all!
Yo Kitty with glasses!
That's right!
Even when I'm on the beach, I'm still doing business.
I am Business Cat!
Oh, yes.
And I also have four ears.
So I can hear you better.
So I know when you're fucking camping.
Alright, let me get this out of the way.
Buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh.
But yeah, I think the hair is really pretty, though.
I love the hair.
Professor Doe Kitty.
But I think the hair is really, really pretty and cute.
I think my mama did a really good job.
Um, on the hair design.
And also, like, uh, my papa's, Leah, uh, making all of me move like this.
Yeah, the hair physics going wild right now.
Uh, for those who don't know, actually, uh, this is actually, um, uh, Charity.
The, the one who designed this and get the concept of this.
The original design and the original concept, um, was the charity auction winner.
So this very first outfit that I revealed was actually, um, conceptualized by one of your dragoons.
Yes, your dragoon.
Uh, one of your, one of yours, uh, picked the Doki Beach episode theme.
The summer theme and helped with conceptualizing the design and where it was going to go.
So, yeah.
She helped with majority of the whole process.
So this was the, this was an outfit that she designed and picked, uh, for all of you guys.
Yes.
The first outfit.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
But let me show you.
Almost forgot.
Sorry, I was so happy with the, I was so happy with the hair.
And I forgot to show you guys the other stuff.
So, I can obviously, I can, um, let me put my shirt back on.
My mood.
So I can take this off.
So, so it won't distract you.
You know, the, the, the jiggle physics won't distract you or anything.
But I can take it off, guys.
I can take it off.
And I also, you know, when I'm playing my FPS games.
I can show my gun.
Um, my water gun.
My non-lethal bullets here when I'm playing FPS games.
And then I can also bring my beach ball up.
The one that didn't give you a concussion.
And then you can see my tail better, too.
You know?
Uh, when I get my tail feathers back during the summer.
You can see that a little better.
Right here.
Uh.
Um, and then we also have...
Oh!
I can also go back to, um, my original hairstyle as well.
So, if I do this and then do that.
My original hairstyle.
I realize my neck gets a little bit longer with that.
Because, uh...
I realize my neck does get a little longer.
But I feel like it should be even longer, you know?
So, um...
If you're gonna stare at my neck, at least stare at my entire neck.
You know?
So, at least now you know where my ponytail ends.
It's a giraffe warrior now.
Whoa!
My giraffe neck.
Also, also so you can see how my ponytail ends, too.
It's for all your artists out there.
Not the long neck part.
But, like, so, like, all you artists out there know how the ponytail ends.
Um.
This is beautiful.
Thank you.
I was born like this.
Um.
What else?
Oh, yeah.
Uh.
I'm trying to make sure I showed everything.
Oh, yeah.
There's the snorkel again.
Um.
Hmm.
But everything from before.
From my bounty hunter skin suit.
Comes along onto my, uh, my summer skin suit.
So, so, you know.
You know.
This was requested by, by her, too.
This was, this was actually requested by, by the charity auction winner.
It was just finished early.
So.
This, this particular expression was actually requested by her.
Including this part, too.
And also, you know.
This is back.
As well.
And then.
Whoa.
As well as the sparkle.
The tears.
The panic.
My long neck.
As you guys all saw.
Um.
Dead eyes.
And then.
Oh.
Whoa.
That's not what I wanted.
Oh.
Hello.
Anyway.
That's enough talk.
I think, dragons.
I think you gotta get some water for your concussion.
For your.
I mean, for your not concussion.
Um.
You gotta get some rest.
How about I'll take you to the chair over there.
Real quick.
Okay.
I'll take you to the chair over there.
So you can, uh.
Um.
You can, like, relax and stuff.
Anyway.
Give me a sec.
Let me.
All right.
Come on.
Go to that chair.
You know you want to.
Whoa.
Oh.
You're passing out.
Whoa.
Here we are.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Ha ha.
Oh, you guys like this?
Um.
So.
It might.
It's not moving.
Because it wasn't done in time.
Ha ha ha.
But all of this will move soon.
Don't worry.
This.
This will be moving.
Soon in the future.
Ha ha ha.
Um.
But yeah.
We have tomato.
Me.
We're in the Doki-verse right now.
So like you might spot different variations of me around here.
Um.
This is where all the Doki's like to relax during the summer.
So.
We all choose like one of the Doki's universes.
And just like.
Like relax your.
Like the Doki with the best beach basically.
You know.
Because we can all travel to each other's universes.
So.
Um.
We decided I'll convene.
We always convene here.
Uh.
Because this Doki has a really really good beach.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
So you can see our tomato Doki here.
Is our resident lifeguard.
And she's doing a great job.
I'm pretty sure she has at least only.
Okay.
Maybe like not only.
But at least like five casualties.
Since she's been our lifeguard.
So I think that's a pretty good record.
You know.
At least from what we know.
From confirmations.
When we found the bodies.
From all the bodies we found.
At least five casualties.
But that's a good record.
I feel like.
Ha ha ha ha.
I think.
I think that's a really good record.
Anyway.
Um.
We have like our cool guy Dragoon back there.
Because he's like.
Mom.
Look.
I'm on camera right now.
Ha ha ha.
I'm on camera mom.
Look at me.
I'm a cool.
I'm so chill.
I'm just a chill guy.
Um.
And then.
We're sort of interrupting.
I know there's a date.
Behind me right now.
But like.
Come on guys.
We don't want to interrupt this date.
That's going on.
Look.
Like.
Come on.
That Chonky Goon.
Like.
They're going to score soon.
So.
We don't want to interrupt them.
Okay.
Like.
We're bros guys.
Come on.
We got to let our bro.
Ha ha ha ha.
We got to like.
Let our bro.
You know.
Like.
Look.
He needs this.
Okay guys.
The bro code.
Guys.
Ha ha ha.
I think it's really really.
I think it's really cute.
I love.
I love the background.
That was made.
Especially for this.
For this particular outfit reveal.
For this outfit too.
Anyway.
Since.
Since you guys saw everything.
Obviously.
I'm here to give you guys the credit page.
Let's see.
Where's the credit page?
I made this.
This is the first outfit reveal.
Where I was like.
Six hours ready.
Before the stream.
And.
Usually.
That never happens to me.
Ha ha.
Usually.
I'm like.
Prepping everything.
On.
On OBS.
Like.
I'm usually like.
Prepping stuff on OBS.
Like.
Uh.
Two hours before the stream time.
Um.
But this is the first time.
Out of all my years streaming.
Where I had everything ready.
Within.
Uh.
With like.
At least six hours before stream.
And it's like.
I don't know if I like that.
Because I was so nervous.
And anxious.
Leading up to this reveal.
I.
Ha ha.
I was.
So.
So fucking anxious.
And nervous throughout it.
Um.
Because I'm just waiting.
And before then.
When I'm like.
You know.
When I'm prepping stuff.
Like.
All I'm thinking about.
Is trying to make sure.
I get everything done in time.
Before the reveal itself.
And.
So like.
I'm not thinking about that.
But this time.
I had to.
Like.
I had to like.
Sit there.
And just think.
And be like.
I hope you guys.
I hope.
I'll be like.
Oh my god.
I hope they like this.
I hope they.
Like this new outfit.
Ha ha ha.
Ha ha.
Anyway.
So.
Um.
You guys might notice.
I'll put it here.
So you guys can see my face.
Um.
You guys might notice.
That.
I've been doing.
There's always like.
A little story.
That goes into every.
Outfit reveal.
So it's not just like.
Even though like.
The story sort of like.
Falls apart at the end.
Ha ha ha.
Cause.
Ha ha.
I'm really bad at making sure.
You guys are still immersed.
Ha ha ha.
I'm.
I'm pretty bad at.
Continuing the immersion.
In general.
Um.
But.
I try to.
Give a little story.
Before each like.
Important.
Like.
Before each reveal.
In general.
And.
Um.
So.
You guys can see.
Like.
You know.
It was a little special.
Um.
Beach episode.
You guys all.
Got.
Uh.
Went to the beach.
And everything.
And a huge shout out.
To.
The animators.
Um.
The 3D animators.
Lucy.
And.
Uh.
Oh.
Hi.
Abigail.
Um.
For the 3D animation.
Tani.
For 3D rigging.
Everything.
Uh.
Not everything.
Sorry.
3D rigging.
The dragoons.
For it.
And.
The sound design.
For Mr. Fox.
Um.
They actually.
Uh.
Mr. Fox.
Did all the sound design.
For that video.
And.
A huge shout.
Um.
The sound design.
Was done.
Within like.
A day and a half.
Um.
So.
I got the video.
Like.
Last night.
And.
Um.
And the animators.
It actually took the animators.
A week.
I think.
And.
Like.
Just a little.
Bit of a week.
Um.
I think like.
Eight to nine days.
To make the entire animation.
So.
Like.
Huge shout out.
To that team.
I asked them if they could do it.
Because.
Um.
I had a different idea.
On how to.
Introduce everything.
But.
I got struck with inspiration on the storyboard, on the concept of the story, of how to introduce this.
So I contacted the 3D animators and was like, Oh, do you think this is possible?
It's okay if it's not, and we can make it super short or anything.
And they're like, no, we can do it.
It's like plenty of time.
Enough time to conceptualize everything and get it all done.
Get it all done in time.
So huge shout out to the 3D animation team for working really hard on all of this.
And making this really cute story to segue into the outfit reveal.
I think you guys might notice that I always like to make outfit reveals really special in general.
Like I always like to have a little story that goes behind the outfit reveal.
And it's not just like, you know, do like outfit prediction and then straight into like, you know, the padding.
I always like to make it like, you know, immerseful.
Like make it more immersive.
So there's like a little, there's like a little, you know, there's like a little story of why there's a beach episode.
And like how you got here and everything.
So, um, I always love doing these little creative things.
Just like when I get, get a chance to do creative things, sit with it and play around.
Um, huge shout out to Nami for the background.
Um, for drawing the entire background of this.
So there's the same artists that did, um, that did this, uh, the saloon.
I almost said salon.
But they're the same artists that did the, um, the saloon, uh, the bounty hunter background.
So, and this is also going to be animated in the future.
It's going to be animated by the same person who did the animation for the saloon.
Um, but obviously, uh, they need more time on it.
So, but it already looks amazing, in general.
Even though it's not animated, it already looks amazing.
And good job on my tomato lifeguard.
I'm so happy that she's doing a great job at making sure no dragoons getting hurt right now.
Also, I'll be showing you guys the sketches and concept art that I received from Nexi, who was the auction winner, and also from my mama.
So, I'll be showing that later.
And I do have, like, some sneak peek stuff to show you guys.
So, if you guys want to see what the sneak peeks are, you got to stay a little longer.
They're, like, sort of like announcements, but they're, like, preview announcements.
That's all I can really say until I actually show it.
There is also, like, a gift, too, that I want to give you guys.
You might notice what the gift is already, from looking at the credits.
Um, anyway.
So, the debut teaser is by RetroVist.
And I've always worked with RetroVist for all my debut teasers from, you know, like, my past and now.
Like, they've been doing all my debut teasers.
I love working with them.
They do such a great job.
You guys already know who my mama and papa is.
Like, Celia and, um, Kamame.
Okay.
Um, and also, uh, now, you'll notice at the bottom, it says, wallpaper.
Yes!
Uh, with every outfit reveal, um, I do, I love giving you guys a free wallpaper to go along with, uh, with the outfit reveal.
So, let me show you guys what the free wallpaper looks like!
I'll post the link later.
Oh, maybe I'll post the link, like, right after I show it to you guys.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
But yes, a shout out to, um, oh my gosh, wait, uh, to Hari... Haru?
Haru?
Sorry, I had to, like, I'll make sure I didn't mispronounce their name.
But Haru, for drawing this wallpaper, this is a free wallpaper that everyone can download.
Um, it's my gift to all of you guys.
So let me post the link really quick right now because I had that prepared and everything because I am a professional.
So you guys want to download the wallpaper right now?
You can.
And you can receive your free wallpaper because I know we all love free stuff.
Yippee!
So yes, huge shoutout to Haru for drawing this wallpaper.
They did it really, really fast too.
I don't know if you guys noticed, but a month ago I was asking for artists who can complete some stuff for me within a very tight timeframe.
Which was like, you know, I think like she had like two to three weeks to do it.
And then she was one of the artists that submitted her portfolio.
And yeah, completed the illustration for all of you guys.
I am planning on getting it animated in the future.
So I can put it on Wallpaper Engine for you guys, for those who want to use like animated wallpapers.
I am planning on getting that animated as well.
There was just no time...
There was just no time to get that done before the outfit revealed.
The reason why...
I know like you guys must be wondering like, Oh Doki, you said like, you didn't have time to get some stuff done in time.
So why didn't you push it a little later?
Because like, I promised the charity winner that I will have it done either before Off Kai or beginning of Off Kai.
So...
And I was okay with it.
It was just like little things, you know, like the animated wallpaper and stuff like that.
The animated background.
It's just little things.
And I was like, you know, I didn't get everything.
Like, you know, I thought like, it doesn't really matter.
Like, you know, those two things, just small stuff.
It was close enough, you know, day one of Off Kai.
Because I have everything else done.
It was just like the animated backgrounds and the animated wallpaper.
It's just little things.
And I was okay with it.
I was just like, you know what?
I got almost everything here.
So close enough, you know, close enough.
Another thing I wanted...
Okay, so I also really wanted to show you guys the concept art that I was sent from Nexi.
How they wanted their...
How they wanted the summer outfit to look like.
So let me show.
I apologize.
I don't remember who the concept artist were.
I believe she got two artists to help with conceptualizing everything.
But I'll show you what I was sent.
I didn't write it down when I saved these.
So I believe Nexi can let me know in chat who they are.
So this was what I was sent.
So basically they wanted the Hawaiian shirt, the water balloons.
At first they wanted like a dragon perched on my hand.
But I changed that into a beach ball.
Oh, it was orca and rice.
Oh, okay.
It was orca and rice that did the concept art.
And then they wanted the dragon crocs and the tail feathers.
They requested to have a tail.
And then obviously, of course, because in my lore that I didn't just come up like an hour ago.
In the summer, I grow tail feathers because it's time to dance.
And it's warm now.
And obviously, I did change some stuff as well.
Because you can see that I made you guys into a beach ball instead.
Because I was like, we're at a beach.
You guys should be all beach ball.
And then I was also sent this as well as another concept art.
So, I really like the hairstyle that they gave us.
That they gave me and my mama.
Because look!
It looks so cute.
Wow!
I can be like...
Let me make myself a little closer.
Give me a sec.
Oh!
Just a little closer though.
I wanted you guys to see my stomach a little.
There.
Don't say I never give you nothing!
Well...
I mean, that's fine.
I'll just...
Let me change the color.
There we go.
Um...
And also...
Alright, so...
With those...
Concept art.
Uh...
This is what my...
Which one was it?
Was it this?
I think this was it.
This was what my mama sent.
Um...
Sent me.
With the concept art that they gave.
Um...
So...
It was...
I remembered...
Um...
It was very hard to...
To...
To figure out the color scheme.
Because I liked...
A lot of these colors...
I liked all the color schemes.
That's why...
Um...
My Hawaiian shirt comes in three different colors.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
So...
I just couldn't pick.
So I was like, I'll take them all.
Like...
I'll take all the color schemes.
Cuz...
They're all...
They're all really nice color schemes.
Um...
Hence...
Yeah, hence my mood ring shirt, that I still don't know what mood comes, goes with what.
Uh, I guess I... I want them on.
Um, so you can see that not a lot was changed in the end from the concept art to, like, the design itself.
And then I believe, um, they also edited this as well.
Uh, so this was edited by Nexi's artist, um, to get...
Wait, let me... let me...
Um...
Hello, everybody!
Hello, everyone!
So, um, you can see that...
Um, this was the artist editing my mama's design to get what they wanted.
Like, what their vision was and everything.
And then in the end...
Oh, and also, here's dad, too, for those who want to know what dad's design is.
His Hawaii shirt is a hot dog.
He has a... he has a hot dog Hawaiian shirt.
Mine's a dragon Hawaiian shirt, and he's wearing a hot dog Hawaiian shirt.
Um, at first, we wanted to do...
We asked if my mama could do...
I think they're called shutter shades.
Um, because, like, I think they were, like, really popular back in the 2010s.
I remember seeing those in 2010s.
But...
I asked.
I think my mama doesn't know what shutter shades are.
Um...
And then I was just like, it's alright.
We can just do sunglasses.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Hahahaha.
I don't remember why we didn't do shutter shades.
I just think...
I think, like, because they were not, like, super well-known.
I guess, like, in Japan.
Like they're not...
They're not, like, well-known...
It's not like a well-known sunglasses design in Japan.
And I don't remember why we didn't end up with Shudder Shades, but he's wearing sunglasses now.
Yeah, he has... he's party rocking right now.
Party rocking's in the house tonight.
Everybody's gonna have a good time.
Also, by the way, don't worry.
We're gonna have a green screen later, guys.
Don't worry.
We'll have a green screen later.
But yeah, those were... I think that's basically all the concept art, really.
And so, you can see here.
After that, after the back and forth, this is, like, where we settled with the little water gun.
So I could use that during my, you know, my Marble Rival streams.
And the Crocs and everything.
And the little hairband and the necklaces and the earrings.
This is where we... this is where we settled in the end with all the conceptual art.
And with Nexi.
So, yeah.
What else?
I wanna show you guys.
But yeah, that's, like, how the concept art came to be.
And from there, we got this.
Okay, don't mind that.
That's just the...
Yeah, from there, we got this, too.
But I love how everything came out in the end.
What else?
I wanna show you.
Okay, so...
You know how?
Alright, I'll give you guys a sneak peek of something.
Okay, so...
You know how?
Um...
I was talking about Dad's Hawaiian shirt.
Okay, well...
Hee hee hee.
In the...
Soon.
Not sure when.
But soon.
Soon.
So...
You know, I was talking about my clothing brand.
Doki Bird by Doki Bird.
So...
This is for your pets, by the way.
It's not...
It's not for you!
Drag rooms!
It...
It's gonna...
Um...
It's gonna be edited a little bit because there's too many hot dogs.
But...
This is a...
Hawaiian shirt for your pet.
It's there...
And he can't stop me!
So...
It's gonna be edited a little bit because there's too many hot dogs.
But...
We got a sample.
I was allowed to share this with you guys.
I mean, to be fair, this is like my own store.
But...
So...
It's gonna look...
It's basically gonna look like...
Okay, I'll show you guys what...
How we're editing this.
So we're gonna edit this...
Later.
We're gonna...
I mean, we sent it to the manufacturer to edit it a little bit more.
But...
It's gonna look like this instead.
Because we realized...
That's too many hot dogs.
So...
Basically...
Like...
It's for like cats...
And dogs.
And I guess like...
Other four-legged...
Animal.
But...
There's gonna be like...
Yeah, so this is what it's actually gonna look like.
Where...
It's not too many hot dogs.
Um...
Because this one was like...
Way too many hot dogs.
So we're gonna...
We're gonna...
We're gonna have it like this...
Instead.
Um...
If you guys are wondering...
Why is there like...
Gamersupps in the back...
Um...
They are my distributor.
So they help me...
Come up with the ideas.
But...
They...
It's not gonna be on the Gamersupp website.
It's gonna be on my website.
Because...
They're just helping me distribute...
Uh...
My merch.
So you're gonna get them...
A lot...
Like...
You know...
We fixed all our merch issues.
So...
Um...
They're helping me with...
Distri...
Uh...
Distribution.
Basically.
And that's why there's like...
Gamersupp logos in the back.
But yeah!
I was like...
I want a Hawaiian...
And then like...
Every crazy idea...
I have for merch...
They basically...
Um...
Help me make it into a reality.
Because...
Do not worry...
You can also...
You'll also be able to get...
My Hawaiian shirt too.
But it's still a work in progress.
I can't...
I can't show it to you guys yet.
Because...
It's still a work in progress right now.
But...
My Hawaiian shirt will also be...
Purchasable in the future.
I just can't show you the sample yet.
Because we're still working on the sample.
And I'm...
Um...
And I'm like changing the color of it.
To look a little nicer.
So you can match with your pet too.
So you can have...
Um...
A Hawaiian shirt with your pet.
But also...
That's not all.
Because this is another thing...
I want to show you guys.
CrocGiplets!
I told you...
Any dumb idea I have...
They can make it possible.
And this was one of the ideas...
That you really wanted to do.
I was like...
I have to get the CrocGibits too.
If I...
Yes.
So basically...
These little things...
Are...
The little charms...
That you put on your Crocs.
Like the holes and stuff.
Now...
So...
You...
Yeah.
So you can...
It's like...
It comes in a whole pack.
So it's not like individual.
So you get...
If you buy the whole...
Like you just have...
It comes in a whole pack and everything.
So the pack comes with all of these designs.
So...
It's gonna...
Ordering...
The items will be up...
Soon.
During my...
Joki merch...
Relaunch.
Um...
Whenever that's done.
But...
I'm super excited because...
Coming out with these like...
Merch ideas...
Has been something I've been wanting...
To do for a very long time.
And I'll have a lot of really...
Funny...
Not funny.
Sorry.
That's not the right word.
I love weird ideas...
That I've always wanted to do for merch.
Because I don't want to do...
You know...
I'm someone that just doesn't want to do...
Just only like...
You know...
Um...
Just acrylic stands...
And you know...
Uh...
Buttons...
And charms.
I want to do more than that.
So...
I'm really thankful...
For Gamer Subs...
For letting me...
Come up with all these...
Merch ideas...
For you guys.
Um...
Because like...
You know...
I want you guys to have more variety in there.
Like...
Make it more usable too.
And stuff like that.
Yeah.
So...
I'm super excited...
That I was actually able to like...
Get that made.
Like when I pitched this idea.
Um...
I'm happy that...
This was one of the things that...
You know...
I could actually do and everything.
I don't think I've had an idea rejected yet.
So...
There's a lot more...
Funky stuff...
That's gonna come out.
And because...
You know what?
Because I'm feeling extra generous today.
I saw people...
In chat...
Were asking about...
A particular merch...
In general.
And I actually...
Just got...
The...
First sample...
Today.
And...
I know...
People were asking about this.
Because I showed this...
Last year.
The concept art for it.
And...
Um...
Never again.
Because...
It's been in pre-production...
For a while.
So I've finally shown...
A sample of it.
And it is...
Ta-da!
Isn't she so cute?
Oh my god!
You guys remember her?
Oh my god.
This was like last year.
And here's her with a hat.
Um...
It's still in sample mode.
So...
Well...
We're gonna be...
Editing this...
Too...
More.
But I just wanted to show you guys...
The progress of everything.
Um...
But I think I'm gonna make the hat...
A little shorter.
Uh...
But yes...
There's Retro Me...
Um...
It's been in development for a while...
And I'm super happy with...
How it's looking so far!
Look how cute she is...
With the eyes and everything!
Oh my god!
She's so cute!
Uh...
And it has a little hat and everything!
But yeah...
Those are all the little previews I wanted to show you guys.
Um...
I think honestly...
My favorite thing out of all of it is like...
This little...
Is this...
This is my favorite out of all of them.
Ha ha ha ha!
The little...
The little crocs symbols...
The little croc accessories...
Is my favorite merch.
Cause like...
I don't know.
You don't really see that a lot.
You know...
As like...
VTuber merch...
You don't really...
See that in general.
So I'm really excited about the...
Um...
About the Crocs VTuber...
The Crocs VTuber merch.
Uh...
Blah blah blah blah...
Okay.
What else do I want to talk about?
Oh!
Yes!
Okay.
Okay, it's green screen time.
Get your cameras ready.
I'm ready to green screen myself.
Well, not green screen.
Maybe like... I think I made purple screen, I think.
Because there's so many colors.
There's so many colors.
So I'm like, fuck, what color do I use?
All right.
Close your eyes.
Now open them.
All right.
I think this works.
No, wait.
Yes, it worked.
It should work.
It should... It's photoshoot time.
All right.
Let me... Okay.
Let me do full body first.
I don't know what should be the default.
Because I like... I honestly... I like... I like this one with the white.
But I also like... I also like it with the blue as well.
So like... I can't tell.
Do you guys like the blue?
Or...
Um... Blue or the... Or the... Oh, wait.
Sorry.
Blue or the teal?
Or green?
I guess that's green.
Blue or green?
I can't tell.
They both look so good.
Um... I like... You like the blue?
The blue?
Okay.
We'll go with blue as first.
Blue or green?
Okay.
I'm gonna make a pull.
Because I don't know what would be the default.
Because I like both of them.
Um... I'll make a pull for now.
And I'll decide... I'll decide the end of the stream.
Blue... Blue... Hawaiian... Shirt... Or... Green.
Did I spell Hawaiian right?
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I just forgot to capitalize H.
You know how like... If you don't capitalize a state...
Or a country... Um... It tells you you spelled it wrong.
And I was like...
Oh my God.
How did I spell Hawaiian wrong?
Um... Alright.
I'll put that in here.
Alright.
Anyway.
So there's the full body.
Here it is with...
The green.
And then... Here it is with...
The white... And the black shirt.
Because I think the white and black shirt is a really...
Cute combo too.
And then...
And then here's...
The physics... In general.
Whoa!
Oh my God.
I forgot the snorkel.
There's so many things.
There... I have so many things.
So many buttons.
I got my stream deck out for this.
I only get stream deck out whenever I'm doing an outfit reveal.
I...
You guys want the BGM?
I mean...
I could put a BGM on.
Okay.
I'll put a BGM on for you guys.
So it's not just me.
There's so many things.
So I don't know what...
To do with pictures of.
I don't...
I don't know.
There's too many intagos.
Too many accessories, guys.
I don't know.
There's so many choices.
What do I put on?
And then there's me with glasses.
My snorkels and glasses.
And then...
Okay.
We'll do...
We'll do faces first.
Faces is always a good idea.
Okay.
Faces with...
I'm like overwhelmed already.
I'm already...
So...
Wait.
There's purple on this shirt?
Okay.
Don't worry.
I got you guys.
Okay.
Watch this.
I made sure.
Because I was like what...
Okay.
Watch this.
What color, guys?
Green?
No.
Because then my eyes.
Okay.
What about...
This color?
Yeah.
We're RGB-ing to figure out what color to use.
We can't use yellow!
Okay.
You think this works?
Oh.
There we go.
There you go.
Red.
Yes.
Okay.
There we go.
We figured it out.
It's...
Okay.
I think...
I think this is a good color.
I'm every color.
I know!
That's what I'm saying!
It's so difficult because I'm every color right now.
All right.
There we go.
This should work, guys.
As long as I don't...
Okay.
As...
It wouldn't work because I have this.
But like you guys don't see that right now.
So it works right now.
Um...
It works right now because I'm not showing this.
I'm only showing...
Um...
My face.
So you guys don't have to worry.
Anyway.
Yes, of course it's colorful.
It's a Hawaiian shirt.
All right.
So...
Um...
Dad here.
And him.
He's so cool.
His little feet's hanging out too.
Wow.
So am I supposed to...
I'm just trying to remember if there's anything else after this.
After the green screen.
The red screen.
I'm just trying to figure out...
Do I have anything else to show you guys after this?
I don't know.
There's Dad.
And then...
There he goes.
Um...
And then...
Guys.
You guys like my new outfit.
Review.
You guys like my first...
My first outfit.
Since I came out as a bounty hunter.
You guys like it?
Yeah?
Good.
That's not gaslighting, guys.
I am not trying to manipulate anybody.
All right.
And then there's...
Confused.
Like...
Whoa.
I'm so confused.
And then...
There's...
Oh my god.
New outfit.
I like new things.
Wow.
Oh my god.
Then we have...
And then obviously the fan favorite.
I would...
I like to say that I was a trendsetter for the long neck VTubers.
I was patient zero.
Even before I came back.
Before it was cool.
Okay.
I need you guys...
We cannot rewrite history here.
Some of you guys were actually making fun of my long neck before then.
Okay.
And now...
Now it's cool.
I...
I lived long enough to find out my long necks are cool now.
I am a trendsetter.
Okay.
And then I have...
Um...
I have...
The blank eyes.
No comment.
No comment on that.
No.
And then...
There's me with glasses.
Right here.
Which glasses is me?
Whoa.
Glasses me?
Now people will think I know what a whole number is.
And...
And then we have...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Okay.
And then...
And then we also have...
The dark circles.
Which is sort of like me every day for the...
For the last couple of weeks.
I have a concert in like...
I literally have a...
Concert in two weeks now...
From now.
And I...
And then I was...
Working on this.
And the concert.
And a lot of other stuff behind the scenes.
And then my birthday.
And all my...
This is how I've been feeling the last couple of weeks.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
And then we also have...
This one.
And then if you want...
There's a combo...
Of it too.
This was like...
Requested by...
Um...
This one was especially requested by...
Uh...
Nexi.
The auction winner.
And then we have...
Cat ears!
Yeah!
Hmm.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Here is...
The cat ears.
Oh my god.
What the Nexi say?
Okay.
Alright, and then... Oh wait, I have cat ears with the telltale.
Alright, and then we have... Oh yeah, so like I said, I'm gonna change the colors of my shirt.
And put the snorkel up.
Oh wait, I can take the... If this makes you uncomfortable, I can take it off.
So like, you know, cause it's all out there.
You know, there's four of them.
And I know like some of you guys only seen two.
But now there's four of them.
And I know that sometimes it might make you guys uncomfortable.
So I can take it off too.
Now I can also take this off as well.
Wow!
And take this off too.
And take this off.
And then I change it to... I change it to black.
Whoa!
Wow!
Alright, any special requests guys?
You guys have any special requests that you want me to do?
Any combinations?
Chat.
Sorry, my belly button is like hidden right here.
Sorry, my little... My pants is... Wait, is it my pants in the shed?
Wait, no.
Where's my belly button?
Okay, I'm trying to figure out anatomy right now.
I... I'm trying to figure out my anatomy.
It's either like behind the shadow right now.
Or it's... It's right here.
I don't know.
I think it's like covered by my pants right now.
I'm pretty sure.
Uh...
I'm pretty sure it's like covered by my pants.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, look at that jiggle though.
I have another thing that jiggles too.
Technically, it's five if you think about it.
You're... You're jiggling too, guys.
Look at that.
Look at you jiggle.
Okay.
Let me...
Put that up.
And...
I can also hold my beach ball with my gun.
Ooh!
See that shadow?
Wow!
Oh!
And here's my tail too.
My little tail.
Right there.
By the end of me.
My snorkel takes up so much space.
Oh.
Here.
Oh my god, guys.
That was a good game.
GG's guys.
GG's.
Good game.
I'm so tired now.
Whoa!
Wow!
Any other combinations?
That you guys wanna do?
No, there is aimbot.
I just forgot to...
Oh, wait.
Is this?
There is aimbot.
But I forgot to...
I forgot to set that up.
So...
I'm sorry.
Oh, it's a sparkleizing gun.
Yay!
Oh, wait.
Let me put the...
Wait, no.
Yay!
Let me put my shirt on.
Pew pew!
Uh...
Okay.
I'll do this for like...
I'll put it up for two seconds, guys.
I see...
I see it!
I'll put it up for two seconds.
So you better get your screenshot ready.
It's done.
It's done!
That's it!
That's all you're getting!
It's gone now!
It's gone!
Don't say I don't give fanservice!
Alright, that's enough fanservice for the next year...
Two years.
You're welcome.
Ask me again in two years, chat.
Yeah.
Yeah, ask me again in two years if you ever want...
If you ever want fanservice again.
Any other special combos that you guys want?
Any other...
I'll do like two more combinations, guys.
Oh, glasses puts tired eyes?
Yeah, I got you.
There we go.
Alright.
One last one.
I've been working all day...
And all night.
And I need to pick up this...
I actually need to pick up this call...
After the stream.
Okay, I'll do the meme face.
That will be the last one.
It's like, that fits.
Okay.
My guy's been so loud since I've done it.
There you go.
A recreation.
I don't even know how I did that so...
I don't...
Guys, honestly, it's actually crazy that I was able to do that so naturally.
Like that...
Whatever that shit the guy said...
Uh...
That shit actually like shook me that hard to be able to do that naturally.
Like...
It never gets old.
Whenever I...
Like people ask me to recreate that face...
It actually takes so many muscles in my face to do that.
I was like, how the fuck did I...
Holy...
It was so bad.
It was so fucking cringe.
And like...
What the fuck am I listening to?
That my entire face just like...
Naturally went into that...
Into that expression.
And it's crazy.
Whenever I have to recreate it...
It takes so much muscle power to do...
Recreate it.
Alright.
Let's move back to...
Let's move back to the beach, guys.
Alright.
Close your eyes.
We're back!
We're back, dragon!
We're back at the beach!
I'm trying to remember if there's anything else...
I wanna announce...
Or show you guys.
Let me look at my fires.
If there's anything.
I don't know if I said everything I wanted to say.
I know I said...
I was like...
I wanna show you guys this...
And that...
And this...
But...
I don't know if that's everything.
I wanna make sure...
That that's everything.
Oh yeah!
By the way...
For the 3D animation...
I was super...
Happy...
Uh...
With...
How...
It ended up looking.
Because like...
I remember like...
Telling them that...
Um...
When they were showing me a work in progress...
I told them...
That like...
The one...
The thing...
The thing I really love about the animation...
Was that...
It reminded me...
Of like...
The spiral...
Outro...
And intros...
When they like...
Go into like...
The various worlds...
Like the humor...
The humor...
And like the...
The like...
Animation for it...
Was so like...
Spiral core...
And it like...
It like...
Even though like...
Even though it wasn't like...
You know...
It's about us dragoons.
I got hit with Spiral nostalgia from that animation in general.
And then I was telling the sound guy, I want the sound design to be very similar to...
Because when I saw the animation, there was no sound in it.
They just sent me a snippet of the volleyball spike.
And then I said, oh my god, this reminds me of Spiral.
And I really wanted to have the sound design to be very similar to Spiral.
Because of how much it just hit me with a wave of nostalgia.
Yeah, so I'll show the animation again at the end of the stream.
So you guys can see it.
And then you'll also be like, oh my god, this does feel like Spiral.
It was so good.
It was really, really cute.
Um, yeah.
Um, I think it's just like the hijinks that you guys get into.
You know, whenever I...
When I'm like, trying to create the lore behind everything.
That comes with doing these like, reveals and stuff.
Um...
I'm trying to remember if there's anything else I want to show you guys.
Uh...
Guys, remember when I was like...
Okay, when I was like...
Guys, before you go, I want to show you these things.
So don't leave yet.
What did I say?
Does anyone remember the list I said?
I was like, okay, I'm gonna do the concept.
I'm gonna show the concept art.
I'm gonna show the green.
I'm gonna do the red screen.
I'm gonna show you guys a preview of stuff that's gonna happen.
Like the merch preview.
No, okay.
Cause my...
I don't have my memory anymore.
Wait, I just said some...
Oh my gosh.
The previews were in my head this entire time.
Um...
Oh.
What's their announcement?
No, there was...
The announcement was just the little...
The little cute merch previews that I wanted to show you.
Uh, which was...
For those who missed it.
It's basically like, you know...
There's this.
And then the little...
The little...
Hawaiian...
Uh...
Pet shirt.
So like...
Uh...
You know...
Your pets can have a little...
Have a little bit of a Hawaiian shirt too.
Um...
So...
I'm happy cause I actually received...
Um...
I actually received a sample...
For the...
For like...
The...
The Hawaiian shirt for your dogs.
So like...
I'm gonna see if dad would like to wear it...
Wear it today.
Hehehehe.
But it's super cute.
I'm really...
I'm really happy about how it...
How it came out...
In the end.
Here, you guys.
Give me a sec.
I need to blow my nose.
Yeah.
No, I'll post it when the...
I'll post it when the shirt goes live.
So I can use it as an ad.
Hehehehe.
I can...
Hashtag ads.
Hashtag PR.
Hehehehe.
That's how you funnel it to the site.
Why are you immune?
Look, you guys already got your fanservice.
No more blowing those...
On like for two more years.
Chat.
For two more years.
Hehehehe.
Yeah, I sponsored myself to advertise DokiBird by DokiBird.
Yeah, I'm really happy that you guys like the new outfit.
I was really nervous.
Because, you know, I'm such a perfectionist.
And like, I always want things to, you know, go well, of course.
Like, every streamer wants things to go well.
So, I was so nervous and I was so anxious and everything.
So, I'm really happy that you guys like the new outfit.
And my beach episode.
And let me change color to change it.
So, yeah.
And then my Hawaiian mood shirt.
And my thermal undershirt too.
I think my favorite part about my new outfit is definitely the hair.
I think the hairstyle is really, really cute.
It's just, I don't know.
It's just super cute in general.
It's like, it's not just like a ponytail.
It has a lot of style too.
A lot of like DokiBird too.
And everything.
Yeah.
Whoa.
And then a little...
A little wing tuffs too at the end.
Whoa.
Yeah.
A 10 out of 10 beach vibes.
Um, alright.
Okay.
So, there was one thing that I wish I had this idea earlier.
But I was also...
I like...
I like had...
Like, I hate how I always get inspirations.
Like, so last minute.
Like, it always just hits me.
I don't know if anyone else experienced this.
But I always get like, really good ideas.
And I get like, super creative.
But I...
I have...
But it's always like, super duper last minute.
When there's like, technically not enough time to make it happen.
So, I think like, two days ago.
I...
It was like, oh my god.
Since I'm doing a beach episode.
I should put tomato me in a bikini.
But...
Obviously, there was no time for that.
I was like, no!
Why did I have this idea?
No!
I could've been...
I could've put tomato me in a bikini for all those people.
And then when people were like, oh man.
I can't believe it.
No bikini.
Don't keep it.
And I'll be like...
Oh...
For all you bikini lovers out there.
Don't worry.
I got something special for you guys.
And all the dragoons are like, oh my god.
Oh my god.
There's an extra toggle where she's gonna take off her shirt.
And it's gonna be a bikini.
And then...
BAM!
I'll show up as a tomato in a bikini.
But I couldn't do it.
I couldn't do it.
It was too last minute.
It would've been so good.
But it's too late now.
It's...
It's too late now.
I was like...
I know some of you guys were like, you could've done it later, Doki.
You could've done the beta switch later.
It wouldn't matter.
It wouldn't be the same, chat.
It would've been the same if I did it later.
It would've...
It could've been so funny.
I mean...
Now you spoil the future trolling.
Okay, but like...
What if I just bring it out of nowhere?
It would be like...
Five months have passed.
And then like...
I'll be like, you know...
In my beach outfit.
And I'll be like...
Oh my god, guys.
I have a new toddler to show you guys.
And then, you know...
Some of you guys are still so...
So gullible.
And be like...
Oh my god!
It must be a bikini!
And then you'll forget all about the idea I said about tomato bikini.
And then...
BAM!
Tomato bikini!
Yeah, I'm the last day of summer!
Just...
That'll be my Christmas present.
But yeah...
I wanted to do that, too.
I wanted to add that into the reveal.
But it was too late, guys.
I...
It was...
It was a brilliant idea!
But I had...
Why am I always so fucking creepy?
I'm creative when I have no time to be creative!
When there's no time to make my ideas happen!
Um...
Don't fall for it, Dragoo!
Because it would have been like...
Oh my god!
I can't believe Toki has another toggle!
It has to be a bikini!
And then I would have like a thousand people unsubscribed after that.
And then after I reveal the tomato bikini...
I lose a thousand subscribers instantly!
Uh...
Not again!
Um...
Anyway...
That was fun, though.
I'm so happy that you guys...
That you guys like the beach show.
My beach episode.
I don't think I've had...
Yeah, I haven't done a beach outfit before.
So...
Um...
It was exciting to...
Design this with...
Um...
The auction winner.
With the charity auction winner.
And of course, there's a lot of...
Outfits...
To look forward to.
Um...
I've been planning...
A lot of outfits in the future.
So...
The next outfit is not...
Um...
Uh...
It's like...
Something I...
Um...
I...
Designed...
Or...
Me and my mama designed.
Um...
So...
Look forward to that whenever that happens.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Well I have plenty of...
Outfits that...
I'm super excited to like release in the future.
I know like one of them is being rigged right now and two of them is actually... another one is being like conceptualized at the moment with my mama and I've already booked another slot as well to be conceptualized in a couple of months later.
I don't know when I'll be done rigging though because the biggest issue is just rigging wise because that takes a lot of time and you know my papa is like really really talented and amazing.
And she's like... she does so much for like different other VTubers as well.
So like it's obviously it's just like it takes time.
It takes a lot of time.
That's why it took a while for me to have you know to... it took me a year to reveal my new outfit.
My first new outfit.
But the next future outfits won't take a year.
Okay, we're not getting an outfit a year.
Starting now, we're not getting an outfit a year guys.
It's it's it's more smooth now after that.
So look forward to that in the future.
Um, but yeah, I hope you guys had a great time.
I'm like, oh my gosh, I'm like...
My mind is like all over the place.
I remember like texting, uh, uh, my friends and my manager and being like, I'm so nervous.
Ah, my head... I was like, my head is all over the place.
Ah, I hope people like it.
What I was also worried about was because like, I know a lot of you guys are at Off Kai right now.
And I was like, oh no.
Oh man.
I hope people... I hope the dragoons are able to watch the new outfit reveal because I know there's so many fun things to do at Off Kai right now.
So I hope you guys are able to watch it.
I'm sorry.
I wanted to do it.
I was like, you know, because I want to do, um, I wanted to do it on like, you know, the weekend or like Friday because, you know, um, so like more dragoons are awake around that time.
But I was like, oh man, but a lot of you guys are on Off Kai too.
Yeah, I think a lot of dragoons were watching on the, on their phone, um, or at their hotel room at that time.
With the, uh, with Off Kai going on.
Thank you all for coming guys for my favorite first outfit reveal.
Wow!
Yeah!
Maybe I'll do like...
Actually, I was like thinking...
I was like, oh, uh...
I don't know if I want to do another...
I'm so busy.
I was like, oh, I want to stream longer.
But I know like, I'm so busy.
I'm like, I'll give all the stuff I have to do later.
But, oh, I just want to talk to you guys more!
But, I think I have to be responsible.
I have to be a responsible adult.
But don't worry.
Things will cool down soon.
I promise.
It's just because we have a concert and birthday in, um...
A concert and birthday stuff that I'm working on at the moment.
That's in like two weeks.
And that's where all my time is...
I...
Oh my gosh.
No, I'm...
I hope you guys will have a great time at Anime Expo for those who are going to the concert.
But, I'll let you guys know, um, for the birthday stream, there is a very special announcement at the end of the birthday stream.
So like, it is very, very ideal for you guys to stay until the very end.
That's all I can say about the birthday stuff on July 4th.
So, um, so like, if you guys could stay at the very end for, uh, on July 4th, for my birthday.
It'll be at 5pm PST anyway.
Like, usually, if you guys didn't notice, all my special event streams or special streams are always at like, primetime for me.
Which is 5pm PST.
So like, my birthday stream will be at 5pm PST.
Because that's usually the time I stream, like, for like, special stuff.
Uh, because it's primetime!
Anyway, but yes.
Look forward to something very, very special at the very, very end of my birthday stream on July 4th!
And I...
Oh, it's a lot of work!
Ah!
Hey, oh!
I know, I...
I knew it!
That's when Toki's gonna debut the tomato bikini!
Don't fall for it, dragoons!
She's beating you!
That's the birthday present for me!
Hey, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
I have a lot of stuff to do.
Um, I have a lot of stuff to do in the next couple of weeks.
It's like crunch time right now for the concert and my birthday stuff.
So I'm gonna head out now.
But I hope you guys enjoyed...
Um, I hope you guys enjoyed my beach episode, everybody.
Um, as always, everyone, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Bye!
I also replayed the...
The dragoon video, too.
Uh, but don't worry.
I'll skip the intro a little bit, because that was like a little bit of a beta switch where it was just an empty background, cause you'll be like, oh, where's Toki?
And then, poof, there's the dragoon!
Anyway, I'll make it so that you guys can see that little animation again.
I'm planning on like, when we have more and more of these little lore videos, these little like animated lore videos with you dragoons, like, it's like a little cartoon segment, like, um, the misadventures of, uh, of dragoon, of the dragoon gang or some shit.
And I'll make, like, a little compilation of all these little miniature cartoons that we've done.
Um, anyway, I'll show that video again.
I'll see you guys later, everybody!
Bye-bye, everyone!
Bye!
Oh, sorry about that.
Oh, can you pass the ball back?